these are busy days if you're a doctor
in Italy as the soaring temperatures
continue so too is a concern for the
elderly Franca santandrea hasn't been
feeling herself over the past few days
it's awful I can't sleep at night and I
can't live during the day it's
impossible I never experienced such heat
all the time I feel like I'm about faint
normal life is already more difficult at
our age the heat just takes everything
out of me
the doctor tells her she needs to drink
much more water something Franca admits
she often forgets he insists that it's a
lifesaver during the heat wave in the
summer of 2022 18
000 people died here in Italy the vast
majority of them being elderly so the
most vulnerable this year Health
authorities are not taking any chances
they have put together a task force that
is being deployed all over the city
it all starts with a phone call this
health clinic follows up more than a
thousand elderly who by and large live
alone checking on them on a daily basis
teams also go from home to home to check
on those with medical conditions like
giovannaticoni her sister Jose Pina goes
out once a day to walk their dog Prince
but for Giovanna it's been tough
it's been nearly a month I've only been
at the hospital or here at home it's
horrible I don't get depressed but I get
very nervous I don't recognize myself
the heat drives me crazy but I'm not
allowed to leave the house so I go from
room to room
both sister told us about their fear of
isolation ever since the covet pandemic
and to have a daily phone call or a
visit is reassuring
they are very scared when we speak to
them they often break down in tears they
are afraid that something happens to
them and no one notices most of those
who died last year were discovered a few
days later because there was no one
around
the worst is yet to come during these
days of a red alert the elderly are a
huge concerned